we have seen that the binomial
distribution plays an important role in
the study of the Bernoulli process and
the reason is that the binomial
distribution describes the number of
arrivals during a fixed number of slots
we will now develop an approximation to
the binomial distribution that applies
to one particular regime and that regime
is when we have a very large number of
slots but we have a small probability of
success in each slot and this is in a
way so that the product of these two
numbers which is the expected number of
successes is a moderate number one
example for such a situation might arise
is the following suppose you are
interested in earthquakes in your city
and you divide time into slots of one
hour during each hour the probability of
having a noticeable earthquake in your
city will be a very small number on the
other hand if you are interested in a
time frame of five years there's going
to be many hours during that time frame
so that n will be quite large but the
expected number of earthquakes over a
period of five years should be a
moderate number and one can think of
other situations where this regime might
arise the one particular situation that
would be very interesting for us is
going to be when we try to take a
continuous time approximation of the
Bernoulli process by dividing time into
very small slots so that we have many
slots but a small probability of success
during each one of those slots so to
start let us look at the form of the
binomial PMF and let us try to develop
an approximation to this PMF when we fix
K to be a particular constant number and
then take the limit as n goes to
infinity and P goes to 0 but in a way
that lambda remains constant
and in particular because of this
relation here we will have P equal to
lambda over N so let us take this
expression and start rewriting it let us
look at the ratio of n factorial divided
by this the denominator has the product
of all numbers going up to n minus K so
by dividing by this number what is left
out of the n factorial is only the terms
that go up to n minus K plus 1 then we
have in the denominator the factor of K
factorial now P is equal to lambda over
N so this term becomes lambda to the K
divided by n to the K and similarly for
the last term we have 1 minus lambda
over N to the power n minus K now let us
rearrange terms here we have a product
of K terms in the numerator here we have
n multiplying itself K times so we can
take a factor of n and place it
underneath each one of those terms to
obtain n over n times n minus 1 over N
times we continue this way all the way
to n minus K plus 1 divided by n take
this term K factorial move it underneath
the lambda to the K term and then let us
split this last term into two pieces in
this manner and now let us start taking
limits as n goes to infinity the first
term that we have here is equal to 1 how
about the second term n divided by n is
equal to 1 1 over n go
to 0 so this term also converges to 1
and by a similar argument all the terms
in this product including this one
converts to 1 the term lambda K over K
factorial remains exactly as is and now
let us look at this term this is
probably familiar there is a basic fact
which tells us that if we take this
expression and raise it to the nth power
what we get is e to the minus lambda in
the limit as n goes to infinity so using
this basic result this term becomes e to
the minus lambda and finally let's look
at the last term remember that K is
fixed is a constant one minus lambda
over N converges to 1 and when we raise
that number to the K power we still get
a 1 in the limit so the only terms that
are left are here and essentially what
we have just established is that in the
limit the probability of K arrivals
in a Bernoulli process or the binomial
probability evaluated at K in the limit
as n goes to infinity and P goes to 0 is
given by this formula here this is the
formula for the Poisson PMF and so what
we have established is that the binomial
PMF converges to a Poisson PMF when we
take the limit in this particular way